[Music]  Kylie Jenner and rapper Travis Scott  appear to couple up as her ex Tyga  parties with Scott Disick again check  out these pics Kylie and Travis looking  cozy in his hometown of Houston Texas  they sat courtside at a Houston Rockets  vs. Oklahoma City Thunder basketball  game  now the possible couple was not showing  PDA but there could it definitely be  something going on here both stars were  at Coachella this month  eyewitnesses even spotted them holding  hands at the Music Festival  meanwhile back home in LA  Kylie's ex Tyga was snapped hanging with  Scott Disick at a tag heuer event this  all comes just after a source told DT  that Tyga has officially moved out of  Kylie's Calabasas compound what Kylie  says they are officially broken up this  time Kylie has put up with a lot of Tyga  but always figured out a way to take him  back  [Music]  you